i quand on voit ces derniers 24 heures
88 morts supplémentaires 30 mille cas de
kovy de dépister c'est en supplément on
se dit qu'effectivement il est
nécessaire d'agir elle c'est le résultat
pour vous du manque d'anticipation du
gouvernement on entend les critiques
d'autres non résidentes vous exactement
moi je trouve quand même que le
gouvernement prend des décisions qui
sont lourdes de conséquences couvre-feu
c'est quand même lourd couvre-feu on
pense à la guerre on a des images dans
la tête
interdiction de sortir avoir des
autorisations pour sortir on est quand
même dans une démocratie on n'est pas en
situation de guerre sanitaire trop
écouté en tout cas tout ça est lourd de
conséquences socialement on en parlera
économiquement et puis individuellement
enfin ne plus avoir le droit de sortir
de chez soi avec uniquement des
autorisations être contrôlés par la
police c'est tout ça est quand même très
lourd
je trouve qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'anticipation et je trouve que le
parlement n'ait pas suffisamment
j'allais dire sollicité on est quand
même dans un pays démocratique où il ya
des représentants là c'est vrai vous
avez du coup interrompue votre examen du
projet de loi de transitoire sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
parce que on a entendu parler d'un
décret en conseil des ministres sur ce
projet de loi d'état d'urgence on vous
serez saisi la semaine prochaine vous
avez l'impression qu'il ya une forme de
couvre-feu aussi sur la démocratie
bien sûr il ya quelque chose qui va pas
bien on discute d'un texte ce qui porte
justement sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et en quelques heures on vous dit on
arrête tout on fait un décret alors on
agit d'abord puis on discute après je
pense qu'on aurait pu solliciter
davantage les commissions parlementaires
on aurait pu davantage sollicité le
président de la commission des lois le
président des commissions des lois et
des commissions des affaires sociales de
l'assemblée et du sénat là il ya des
questions au gouvernement le premier
ministre
dit au président du sénat attendez vous
à savoir que dans quelques heures on va
faire quelque chose
vous auriez souhaité un grand débat
démocratique à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat
au moins avec les représentants des deux
assemblées
je veux dire n'avaient pas été
consultées où on a découvert que vous
l'avez découvert à la télé quoi je veux
dire vous écoutez monsieur macron pour
savoir ce qui se passe ce projet de loi
d'urgence sanitaire vous allez voter ou
pas vous allez donner c'est pleins
pouvoirs si l'on peut dire
alex discuter un texte est fait pour
être discuté je pense que il est
important qu'on prenne des mesures donc
pas s'opposer à des mesures sanitaires
en revanche on peut discuter les
conditions d'application de tout ça il
faut que le parlement puisse contrôler
notamment les atteintes aux libertés
publiques
ce sont vos libertés je suis encore une
fois ne pas pouvoir sortir de chez soi
sauf autorisation
c'est pas rien